so I first came to Carnegie Mellon in
1978 is a young graduate student having
been undergrad at Stanford and what
attracted me to Carnegie Mellon at the
time was just the diversity of the
program and how strong it was really
what made it great were the people who
were in the computer science department
I get to work with and learn from some
of the Great's of the field and my
advisor Bob sproul has remained to today
an important part of my professional and
personal life and people like Ivan
Sutherland and many many others and then
as I started my professional career it
just was clear to me that Carnegie
Mellon had had such a great impact upon
me that I felt I wanted to get
re-involved with it so much of what I've
learned both professionally and
personally and then even from a family
perspective came during my time at
Carnegie Mellon and so in that sense I
sort of felt an obligation to give
something back to an institution that
had been such an important part of my
life and of course now still is
everything I find myself doing I always
think there's an aesthetic to it both
from an engineering perspective but also
from a sort of outside aesthetic and
clearly being an apple a lot of what we
do really involves building things that
aren't simply great to use but they're
beautiful to look at and I think that's
a something the Carnegie Mellon has
helped me really understand throughout
my career as well as of course being
married to an artist she's really helped
me understand as well how art is
important and how artists think about
things and I think that form of thinking
that non-technical way of thinking can
be critical to creating really great
products and so part of what attracted
me to go into Apple for example was they
bring those two elements we bring those
two elements together if you look at the
pace of Technology and you look at
what's happened over the last hundred
years and then you look at what's
happened over the last ten years and
even what's happened over the last year
you realize it's this rapidly increasing
ability to go do things that even a
couple years ago we run imagine
well when you look at the kinds of
things that the web has enabled and the
number of people connects and people
talk about social networking three four
or five years ago one couldn't imagine
that we would have the capability you're
going to do that so it's just an
exciting time because we're getting more
and more the tools that enable us to go
build products that change people's
lives or if they don't change their
lives at least or things that people
love to go use and not all of these will
be technical in many cases they'll be
artistic works when you look at what the
web has done for example to enable
musicians and artists and filmmakers to
reach audiences that previously you
couldn't go reach it's amazing okay and
so much of that groundbreaking work the
foundation of that is based on things
that happened at Carnegie Mellon